say fur Rahman died in hospital while in
police custody two weeks ago his widow
believes he was tortured and didn't
receive proper
care the government is responsible they
tortured my husband and I want justice
but I don't expect it from
them above the bed a megaphone no longer
in use the essential equipment of an
activist member of the opposition BNP
beside her television news declares the
victory of prime minister Shea the BNP
boycotted the election after thousands
of its local leaders like fazlur were
jailed charged with fermenting
pre-election violence the Prime Minister
now describes the party with whom she's
vied for power for decades as a
terrorist
organization this is the headquarters
building of the main opposition
Bangladesh nationalist party as you can
see it's locked and shuted and has been
since last October when the police
described it as a crime scene it's hard
to imagine a parallel like the
Republican Party in the United States or
say Britain's labor party completely
shut down they did that by uh somehow
putting everyone who could take a
decision into jail Ted Hussein was
foreign secretary under a neutral
caretaker government in the mid 2000s he
says all semblance of democratic order
in Bangladesh has broken down it was
sort of one party
election just like just like today sort
of a one party
State um I think we are very close to
one party
State this woman is a BNP local leader
arrested and badly beaten by plain
clothes police at a demonstration two
months
ago when they couldn't drag me into the
waiting car they hit me on my arms one
of them said shoot her on the spot
another person said cut her tongue out
we don't need to kill
her she lost a tooth but got away with
her life for Bangladesh the price is
democracy itself Jonah Hall elazer
Ducker make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer